yo what's up everybody this procedure
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel legendary weapon guide
today we're gonna be looking at the
blowfly a blowfly is a legendary doll
pistol it's reds text reads of these
flies it always had is corrosive it
isn't always gonna be corrosive
elemental damage pistol and because it
is dull it is always going to have a
burst fire while zoom now I have the
tackle tactical blow fly so it I believe
the tactical prefix gives the bird it
gives the increased weapon stability now
overall this is a decent pistol I say
decent because for legendary it is
decent compared to most pistol I would
definitely rank it above since it does
good damage as good accuracy pretty nice
fire rate quick reload speed good
magazine size and good throw damage and
chance that being said at for a
legendary I think it could be a lot more
and also because it's corrosive it's
kind of had a slight disadvantage as to
non elementals or other elementals
because there are not that many elements
there are not that many armored enemies
in this game there is Felicity there's
our KS / v I forget which one as a 5 r
NS and there are a few armored just
infantry mobs but other than that
there's really not that much so it
always being corrosive you're put a bit
of a disadvantage it is very similar to
the borderlands 2 hornet it's it's close
to a reskin I think I think the Hornet
was doll corrosive as well but
regardless we're gonna i'm gonna show
you how to find it and a little gameplay
of it so I hope you enjoyed so to find
this we're gonna want to head to the
veins of Helios so first stop on that
road is Jack's office once you get to
Jack's office head out to the Hyperion
hub of heroes heroism make a hard left
and just go straight until you get to
the veins of Helios if you haven't if
you don't know where that is then you
won't be able to do this since you have
to do a mission a few missions before
this in the veins of Helios do this now
you can activate this and kill this guy
you're gonna be killing a / farming
hood I think I could yeah you can do
this after you do the mesh and eradicate
now you can see on the map we're gonna
go in this little look at the
contaminated area box where you do go
for the emission eradicate and that's
where we're gonna be farming him here's
a farm completely farmable boss
I guess boss he's kinda like a boss a
unique character
he's completely formable however so is
the Dalek unit the class rep unit that
is with him you can farm both of them if
in the quest for the erratically quest
you choose to capture the Dalek unit
instead of killing him so you're for
that eradicate mission when you get it
you're gonna get it from Jack's office
from chairman Tassadar you're gonna want
to capture the claptrap claptrap Dalek
not killing so I'm going to show you up
the heaters been a straight path you
basically haven't been able to choose
where you want to go but once you get
out of this doorway you're gonna make a
hard right and you're just gonna jump
off the cliff you're gonna jump and look
up and forward and when you use your
boost a lot of times this platform will
catch you if you work if you're not
going to make it but a lot of times it
won't be there as well and this is
definitely a jump you can make without
it so once you get to this bottom
platform hop on the green pad it'll take
you up and you're gonna get on another
green pad or blue green pad except
you're not gonna let it take you where
it's aimed at you're gonna get on it and
go to the left and boost
you're gonna aim your body to the left
and boost so you can you're gonna be
able to go straight to the
contaminated area so once you get onto
this roof just jump across and you see
that airlock leads you to the
contaminated area so jump look up boost
this is the semi-hard to jump to make
but you can definitely land every time
if you're diligent about boosting
forwards so you're gonna get into the
airlock cycle the airlocks there's gonna
be a unique guy called Laszlo
he's completely farmable as well for a
unique item called D fries easy and so
you can just kill and get rid of them
run through all these enemies there's
gonna
a handful of guys are getting your way
just keep going forward moving deeper
and deeper into the camp contaminated
area because damnation there's nothing
to you to my knowledge you get some
green effects around the screen but
nothing else so you're gonna get to this
back room and you're gonna be faced by
the clap
duck the clap like who is a shocked
enemy was pretty tough actually and he
is has armored so killing with corrosive
pistols you see these are some here's a
fizzles I have before you get the
blowfly it's kind of interesting you get
the corrosive blow fly from the guy
who's with an arm one of the few armored
enemies in the game so you're gonna get
to egg hood just take him out he's not
too hard you take him out and he drops
the blow fly you see it drop it right
there now it is as I said it's pretty
alright pistol I personally like my TPMS
that you saw me kill the clap like with
before I am I have done a guide for the
three d de dot one which is the drop
from the clap like so both of these guys
I have videos before they drop so that's
gonna be basically it for the video I'm
gonna end it with some gameplay of me
fighting uh rk5 I hope you enjoy it I'm
probably just gonna stop talking put
maybe put some music on and leave just
enjoy the fight and yeah I appreciate if
you watch the video this long make sure
you keep looking at my channel because
I'm gonna be doing more and more
legendary guys I already have done quite
a few and if you haven't seen those
check them out and thanks for watching
peace
you